a police officer in Pennsylvania has
been charged with criminal homicide in
the shooting of seventeen-year-old black
teenager named Antoine Rose Junior On
June 19th criminal homicide if you
haven't heard that term before it can
include both manslaughter and murder in
Pennsylvania and prosecutors later will
say whether they're going forward
specifically with manslaughter or murder
charges the officer in question is
Michael Ross Feld and Ross Feld claims
that the victim had something in his
hands when he was shot could have been a
weapon multiple witnesses then came
forward and said there was absolutely
categorically nothing in Antoine Rose
juniors hands when he was shot by the
officer he was also shot in the back
three times in this incident that
started with a traffic stop of the car
that Rose was in Rose wasn't the driver
police said the reason for the stop was
that the car resembled one that was used
in a drive-by shooting that exact same
night during the traffic stop Rose gets
out of the car and is seen on video from
witnesses showing his hands initially
before fleeing no weapon was ultimately
found on him and he was shot three times
in the back by the police officer in
question this police officer had been an
officer in the area for many years but
had been sworn in to this particular
Police Department in East Pittsburgh 90
minutes before the shooting and had been
on patrol for a few weeks before the
shooting he had been previously
dismissed from another position because
of what are being called discrepancies
between his sworn testimony and what
evidence revealed for me the real issue
is the shooting in the back and it can
be said well the having a gun or not
wasn't clear maybe the witnesses all
said there was nothing in Rosa's hands
but maybe the officer genuinely thought
that there was a gun in Rosa's hands but
even if the officer believed that there
was a gun because of implicit racial
bias for example in a courtroom it is
really tough to get a conviction when
you have at least the possibility that
the officer believed that this
individual had a gun in his hands but
then you get to the shooting in the back
three times you can only shoot someone
in the back
if they're facing away barring you know
some really specific wrestling on the
ground type scenarios that we have no
reason to believe happened in this
particular case but we've seen cases of
suspects shot in the back by police
which still don't lead to convictions
and that's my prediction here I'm
curious to hear what you think Pat I
think there will be no conviction of the
officer criminally and then there will
be some kind of a civil suit against
either the officer or the police
department for responsibility for
Antoine Rose juniors death and the
reason I say this is not that I
personally defend the actions of the
police officer it's just based on what
we know probable cause the officer had
probable cause to stop this vehicle
because it matched the description of
one used in a drive-by shooting that day
number two if you pull the car over and
you believe that it's the car that was
involved in a drive-by shooting that
gives you reasoning for thinking that if
somebody in the car tries to flee that's
a public danger because if the car was
involved in the drive-by shooting or at
least I believe that it was and then one
of the people in the car flees it stands
to reason that they are armed whether or
not I actually see the weapon so this is
not my defense of the police officer
it's how it would likely be defended in
court I'm not saying it's right and I'm
not saying it's accurate I'm saying this
is a strong defense in front of a jury
and we know from experience that it's
really difficult to prove that an
officer didn't fear for their life yeah
and even outside of the specifics of
this case we've seen this before right
there's a pattern when we think it's
pretty clear that the police officer did
the wrong thing and maybe should be held
for you know some criminality some you
know even manslaughter murder perhaps
they typically just get away with it and
if there is any consequence it's just a
slap on the wrist maybe getting fired
from the police force in their defense
get away with it imply something
different then are often acquitted get
away let let's at least give the benefit
of the doubt that even though we would
like these situations to be different
that there is a an apparatus of
sort of what constitutes the possibility
that you feared for your life what sorts
of circumstances justify lethal force
I'm not saying I agree with them
colloquially but I am saying if we're
going by what the justice system would
dictate not all of these are quote
getting away but it's the reality that
you need to meet a certain burden of
proof to secure a conviction in these
circumstances we'll see what happens and
I'm curious to hear from people in the
audience what they think about this
story